RYA
Danny
do you know why you're here?
I have these blank spots.
DANNY
Sometimes I think that night marked me.
Everything that came afterwards…
DANNY
couldn’t be a coincidence could it?
POLICE
On the ground!
Get down on the ground!
MATTY
Brought in a kid last night.
Might be something that interests you.
Danny
RYA
you don’t really seem like a dangerous person.
Can you tell me how you ended up here?
Loser.
BILL
Hey! I’m gonna kick your little wirey ass.
DANNY
Please no.
YITZHAK
Go!
Wanna come in clean yourself up?
YITZHAK
You are safe now.
RYA
It never struck you as strange
that this man just showed up to save you?
Just figured I was lucky.
Have you ever been lucky?
No.
FRANK
There’s glass everywhere.
MATTY
Signs of a struggle, blood on the floor.
What about the girl?
MATTY
No sign of her either.
I’m thinking that he offed her.
What did you do?
STAN
This wasn’t a random shooting.
He’s hiding something.
What happened in that house?
RYA
Where did they all go?
I have these blank spots.
RYA
They’re not the only people
close to you to disappear
RYA
are they?
MATTY
Do you think these were all victims?
RYA
Can you see how all of this can seem like it was you?
DANNY
Wait do you think that I’m the one pulling the strings?
What if I said I do?
I’m not!
RYA
Danny I’m trying to help you.
DANNY
I didn’t shoot anybody.
STAN
His best interest is to plead guilty.
DANNY
They’re all in this together.
RYA
If I’m right...
Danny may be innocent.
RYA
What are you not telling me?
What are you not telling yourself?